what's going on guys national master james cantor
iii here with chess.com and today we have game of
the day with the computer chess championships
with the white pieces we have komodo and with
the black pieces we have leela chess zero let's
get right into it here we go e4 and e5 knight f3
knight c6 bishop c4 and bishop c5 an italian game
a joko piano a quiet game many names to this but
sometimes these games aren't as quiet as they say
they are after bishop c5 there's c3 here intending
d4 just getting a big center threatening a bishop
that's already out developed now after knight f6
we're just saying hey play d4 anyway and if you
capture capture we might just go bishop b4 check
and take on e4 and have a good game now after d3
which is the more positional just slow methodical
way of playing i'm going to get my pieces out and
then i'm going to try to push d4 eventually even
expanding on the queen side with moves like b4 and
a4 so after d3 d6 we're just going to push upon in
the center lock the bishop outside the pawn chain
like the light square bishop did as well and open
our bishop up for potential attacks castles and
then a6 here very multi-purpose type move here
b5 but also the biggest thing is bringing the
bishop back to a7 and we're going to sit here
and be a monster for forever as long as the bishop
e3 doesn't come in now rook to e1 and then bishop
to a7 he does or she leela chess actually brings
the bishop a back to a7 here and eyeing this big
diagonal what we call here is a snake in the grass
guys if you don't see the snake in the grass and
you step on it or you come near it what's going
to happen it will bite you you wouldn't even
know it so this bishop here is doing exactly
that sitting from the other side of the board
a4 expanding on the queen side stopping queen
side expansion um and tempo well for black here
which which would be b5 so a force blade and then
castles and h3 stopping bishop g4 and also knight
g4 which could be extremely annoying and if bishop
to e3 would easily just take with our knight so
h3 is played and then bishop to e6 you
would sometimes you would see h6 here
more of the human-like move this is why they
call it a quiet game because they kind of do
the same moves back and forth minus the knight
and the pawn being in different squares here
if this would be absolutely symmetrical if the
knight was on c3 but there's this knight on c6
and the pawn on c3 makes it just slightly
different so instead of h6 bishop to e6
here guys and this is something that
you can take uh for your own games
so that you can understand what you're playing and
then actually have better games here bishop to e6
is not the scariest looking move it honestly is
a very good move guys and if bishop takes well
don't worry about the double pawns here as you
see we already have the rook file and the bishop
here as well our in the f2 square indirectly as
an x-ray but also the center pawns actually give
extra protection and we can undouble our pawns
later with a move like d5 and then we have
actually a strong sensor while opening the f file
it's a very strong move here from leela chest zero
bishop to a6 and knight to a3 here saying that
if you capture i'm just going to bring my knight
to c4 so that's why they say sometimes to
take is a mistake you don't always want
to just capture just because there is a capture
there as you see bishop takes e6 was not played
just yet and then h6 here now we're like okay you
know what no bishop g5s no knight g5s at all so we
play h6 and now surprising move actually bishop
takes e6 is now on board then after f takes e6
there's a lot of play for black here uh of course
d5 is a move you also have the open rook file here
so there's things that you have to watch out for
with the white pieces and then b4 from komodo b4
is a just an expansion move on the on the queen
side of the board maybe playing c4 bishop b2 even
b5 just to get some space and then here we go
we break open with d5 says leela chest 0 here
now this pawn is hanging guys chest is simple math
two versus one so of course white's gonna win this
pawn but that's at a cost if something like e
takes d5 and e takes d5 then knight takes e5 and
the knight takes e5 we have bishop takes f2 then
king takes f2 and knight g4 with a double check
and also a discovery on the e5 let's actually put
that on the board here so you guys could see that
bishop takes f2 knight to g4 with a double check
nasty here and after the king moves knight takes
e5 ouch right so that's very scary and and also
looking at this position the pawns are now very
very strong e4 could be a threat and again guys
this is a very very a realistic threat something's
going on here on this diagonal so instead of
taking on d5 we see queen to e2 here actually just
defending getting the queen off of the file as
well maybe putting some extra pressure here let's
see what happens knight h5 beautiful move here
from leela chess zero i really like this move here
guys intending moves like knight to f4 and knight
to g3 and also opening the rook file let's see
what happens next rook to b1 here just putting a
rook on the file getting some extra pressure here
play on the side that you're strongest on and
white is strongest on the queen side right now
so there is some queen play there and queen side
play knight to g3 beautiful move here um intending
i'm just hitting the queen very simple but you
cannot take my knight because the snake on the
other side of the board will bite you and also
it's just an illegal move but the bishop here
is actually doing a great job so knight g3 is
actually a beautiful move queen to a2 here guys
and here we go it's about to get crazy black to
move what would you actually do in this position
here we go guys monstrous move brook takes f3 it's
on the board it's there what are you gonna do with
life now well in this position you literally have
to take the road because there's nothing else to
do so now you're just here now we have gone down
this rabbit hole here and we have to go through
it no matter what happens we don't know if we're
going to come out dead or alive here let's see
what happens rook takes f3 g takes f3 you got
to have to you have to take that there and then
we follow up with a strong move especially if you
do a sacrifice you should always try to follow up
with very strong moves sometimes you have quiet
moves that you need to make or quiet connectors
to make the whole combination work but here this
is actually a very strong move queen f6 intending
easy move queen f3 okay bishop b3 we have to get
rid of this bishop this bishop is the problem
piece on the board we have to get rid of it so
we just move out of the way because our knight is
hanging now leela chess plays knight to h5 and if
we do remove the bishop here the f4 square is now
forever ours it's going to be a long time for this
knight to try to capture ours and if even a rook
it's going to be hard to get this knight off of
f4 and it's also delivering checkmating threats
knight h5 he takes d5 intending pawn takes and
queen takes d5 with check and leela chess joe
just moves out of the way he had no checks for you
you can have a second pawn if you like 97 and then
komodo's like you're going to give it to me i'm
going to take it i don't know what's going on here
pawn takes e6 but this this is blocked so we don't
have to worry too much about this here we go guys
queen h4 and tinging queen takes h3 maybe rook f8
rook f5s or knight f4 this is about to get crazy
here bishop takes a7 and should i take the bishop
back or what should i play here in this position
bishop takes a7 is on the board guys most people
just take the bishop back i mean take your piece
keep material even but not leela zero we don't
care about material even gary kasparov says that
activity trumps material most times so if your
piece are active if your pieces are very active
material sometimes doesn't matter you do need
pieces to help with this wind but at the same time
if you have something better when you find a good
move look for a better move like emmanuel asker
says bishop takes a7 queen takes h3 guys knight
knight f4 is coming so you have to do something
rookie four looks good that's what happens
because knight at four i'm just going to chop
that knight and have a nice day because you got
two mini pieces over here attacking my king and
then rook to f8 so we're going to bring another
piece into the game actually knight f4s all kind
of things are happening now here knight to c4 was
the move but actually i think bishop c5 according
to stockfish was the best move here but knight
to c4 and knight f4 okay it's it's coming guys it
mates on the board we have to do something now
instead of rook takes f4 what happened here was
actually knight to e3 here's a beautiful move guys
black to move to have you done your tactics today
puzzle rush all of that good stuff guys what would
you do with the black pieces now black to move
here we go guys a special move rook f5 and live
rook f5 and live if you take my rook obvious
reasons queen to g2 and now we have a third piece
in the game usually it takes two to three pieces
usually three for a successful attack sometimes
you need to sacrifice one in this case it would be
the rook and you mate with the other two which is
knight in the queen so the more pieces the better
here but rick f5 is a beautiful move intending
rook g5 checkmate in a few here so after rook
takes f4 because he has to get rid of this rook
i'm going to play what do you think you're going
to play what are you going to play what are you
going to play rook ace 5 i'm not going to take
anything i'm not going to take any piece on the
board i'm going to play rook h5 and we're live
game's over what do you do nothing queen to d5
queen of d5 giving up my queen was the best move i
could find here says komodo but it doesn't matter
because queen h1 is checkmate and have a nice day
beautiful game here another attacking monstrous
engine genius game here guys something that you
can take away from this game again is absolutely
using this f file like how lila chest did here
beautiful sacrificing on f3 playing queen
f6 with the follow-up move not caring about
material 97 i mean we sacrificed the rook then
gave up two pawns i mean gave up a bishop here
and destroyed i mean absolutely beautiful chess
here sacrificing another piece i mean almost like
leela chess and tal are best friends absolutely
this is absolutely ridiculous here beautiful play
beautiful play and after rook takes instead of
taking it back like most people would maybe even
rook takes or pawn takes pawn takes runs in the
night takes so maybe rook takes rook g5 rook g4
but rook h5 there's nothing that you can do to
stop the checkmate on h1 beautiful even rook h4 we
just take it and go back to may here guys this was
a beautiful game a beautiful monstrous computer
game that we watched here today guys and that is
awesome so i hope you guys enjoyed the video i'm
national master james canty the third here with
chess.com and i'll see you guys on the next video